sos racisme a organisé aujourd'hui au
bois de vincennes ce qu'il a appelé son
grand reng qu'à un spectacle meetings à
travers lequel à quelques semaines de
l'élection présidentielle le mouvement a
montré qu'il s'engageait désormais
résolument dans le combat politique
jean-pierre 15 au rendez-vous à rully
c'était le mot d'ordre aujourd'hui des
militants de sos racisme
ils étaient trente mille selon les
organisateurs une occasion pour
certaines vedettes comme guy bedos il le
renouveler leur soutien
la possibilité aussi pour leur leader
d'affirmer l'engagement politique du
mouvement certains dans notre mouvement
n'ont voulu voir que fait les concerts
ils ont oublié que dans les concerts il
y avait la parole et la musique
ils ont voulu faire semblant de
l'entendre que la musique et d'oublier
les paroles
le leader des semences racisme a précisé
ensuite qu'il allait présenter six
projets doit aux candidats concernant le
droit de vote
le code de nationalité les expulsions
les bavures l'école et le logement puis
il a précisé son choix vendu comme moi
deux ministres d'état monsieur balladur
s'y asseoir chirac est le meilleur pour
lutter contre l'immigration
m
manifestement le candidat du rpr lui a
choisi et court après les voix du front
national
alors nous aussi nous serons choisir
deux chirac nous en souviendrons le 24
avril
l'intervention avait été précédée d'un
message télévisé de sympathie de
françois mitterrand et le président
avait renoncé à venir en personne comme
cela avait été un moment envisagée
accueil